okay so the question everybody wants to
know do you want the smoke again yes of
course that's the question so I saw
during the lead up to the fight he goes
I bet you or he speaks like Frankenstein
by the way yeah
nah his head looks like the Easter
Island
they call him hands of stone but he got
a head of stone I'll tell you that I'll
break bricks man I'm telling you I can
break bricks
um but yeah he um he said like oh I
don't think he's going to want to he
need a rematch I'm like [ __ ] he doesn't
know me yeah I won't fight you until I
beat you yeah I don't give a [ __ ] I'll
be 60. I'll come to your Favela I'll
knock on your [ __ ]
my walking stick and be like yo you want
me right now like we need to go because
I that's just me I don't give a [ __ ]
even if it's just one cool beat you how
long I could beat him how long you want
to give it to let your body heal I'm
worried for you this guy looks like
Sagat from Street Fighter I'll [ __ ] him
up I don't I can't no but okay so I
gotta get this fixed I get I mean that's
fixed what else you gotta get fixed I
keep these things away from the media
because they like to run with it so I
don't want to it's not because of you
guys yeah I'm just curious how much time
you thinking I definitely want to watch
Perth as a fan
um and then that's wrong so Volks
fighting is yeah for the lightweight
belt it's amazing well honestly people
on the resume Vlog I'm telling you
different I know you guys don't know
stupid because you know again people
just brings his own pee on purpose yeah
yeah
there's nothing that can stop it no but
um yeah I want to watch that as a fan
and just chill and then
um yeah we'll see what happens but this
is the main thing I want to get fixed
first now now my question is
the time is important because is he
gonna fight again before he fights you
or is it going to be immediate rematch
That should be me um hold up
I didn't think about that I mean even if
Anne are you worried if he fights
someone else
and he loses I'm thinking about that
right now look let's go fight him I'll
probably just fight
himself yeah literally I'll just go
through that in my head I haven't
actually thought about that but I think
even if
he if maybe I had surgery not that I
would maybe or need it right but if I
did and he fought someone else in the
interim and then lost the belt to that
guy I'll probably just come back and
fight him yeah that's far yeah because
I can beat him I know you can be all
right why do you feel more like
because I've been there with him too
many times now and I've also taken his
best shots in different gloves
um I took him down I controlled him
um I know what to do now because I I
compromised his legs early but then he
compromised mine as well but he just did
his it's like if I hit his perineal
nerve we wouldn't be having this
discussion right it'll be different
right he would have been gone if you
know
yeah in another parallel universe all
that kind of [ __ ] but yeah
um he just did it better and I just know
I can beat him I know I have his number
but again he just somehow gets a dunk
because he's got more confidence knowing
you took his hardest shot in four ounce
gloves and it didn't drop you yeah there
was something I was willing to stand
close closer I pushed I was right there
something in his face hand fighting yeah
because I was right there and I'm like
oh I can see things I was fast is that
what you were most worried about before
the fight is his hands
uh I was worried yeah it was it was he's
got good shots he's got a good right
hand good jab stuck with it a couple of
times
um me as well there was one knee I
remember like it got really close yeah
and I was like oh [ __ ] yeah that was
really close I can't remember if I don't
think I shot or something for a body jab
I think I went for a body jab and he
shot the left knee up and I was like
okay that's close after you somersaulted
that was just automatic breakdance
Instinct you know that was so [ __ ]
cool I know your foot left you or
whatever but then she looked cool not
because like oh my God thank you but um
for me when it happened what are you
gonna do lie on the ground yeah because
then I'm just sitting duck yeah so as I
fell down it's just this is what
freestyle freestyle comes into play so
as a dancer freestyling is a skill and
you can really train yourself how to
Freestyle how to actually let your body
just roll with the flow so as I fell
down I could have done the old butt
scoot butt scoot yeah like every other
anime fighter but then as I was falling
down I was like oh break dance boom
backwards rolled and I got up and I was
like okay here comes the flying as I was
upside down I knew there's a flying me
or something coming but he didn't throw
it but he stalked me and I was able to
still get out of Dodge I still haven't
watched the fight I will watch it you
just watch highlights just I saw things
on Instagram and whatnot and I'm happy
with the way it looked the way it went
but um yeah I just wish I got the wind
very close it was yeah five seconds in
the first round three seconds in the
first round I'll [ __ ] this guy up but
again he's got bragging rights he's
beating me yeah you know so he can have
all that yeah is it weird as I've seen
we've seen your profile grow obviously
now your fights are House of highlights
Bridge your report is it how does it
feel is it like [ __ ] infuriating when
you're seeing the fight highlights of a
fight you lost right after oh not really
no not this one no but um for me [ __ ]
at least the ESPN did me dirty
[ __ ] up I was like okay I was talking
to DC after the wins and then I was
talking about the first fight and then
they pull up highlights of the first
fight okay watch this bit and they
pretty much assure like I think 20
seconds of just his shots and I'm just
like you ain't slick [ __ ] you Mickey the
eight times that he got tagged in that
fight he was talking about like yo I
struck him all the times and then they
show the only eight times that he got
hit because I was trying to talk about
how I was skinny back then and I got all
these angles on him and I was I was
cracking them but now if I get those
angles on them it's different and I was
like okay watch these highlights it
knows it's like
do you think that he was concerned about
your power
more surprised by it surprise yes
because yeah I saw his eyes when I hit
him yeah it's like he he got hit in the
if I believe they call it gb20 it's like
right here behind under the air yeah you
start bleeding yeah it started bleeding
I mean his ears cry blood
and then it comes back up and I went for
uppercut and I I pulled it back and oh
[ __ ] boom I kind of wish I threw the
uppercut I wish it do more yeah
through the hook but um but the uppercut
is dangerous against a guy like him who
likes to throw that hook yeah whatever
he was hurt so when I it was a good fake
and then hook within referee Marxist
jumped right in yeah I was like [ __ ] and
she is like he's like oh [ __ ] yeah even
when he got up for the second round he
was still kind of wobble he was a little
bit but he's just again Comeback Kid
he's is that [ __ ] I don't know what
they have in the [ __ ] joke would you
wrestling more next fight you think uh I
will take less leg kicks and definitely
wrestle more they know I could wrestle I
could wrestle trust me all these they're
[ __ ] it's so easy it's not easy
wrestling's hard training for wrestling
is hard yeah
cardio is different too I've noticed
that with Fighters like exactly there'll
be guys that this Strikers on the feet
can fight 20 rounds it doesn't matter
they get caught in a grappling situation
your muscles are contracted
yeah it's like in different positions
squeezing lactic acid just builds up and
eventually your arms get tired did you
think you were gonna choke them out at
one point when I was on the ground yeah
I was trying to find the next so you try
to put in there and then he got the leg
out and I was like okay cool and I was
listening to my corner it was hard to
hear my corner a little bit in this in
this maybe it was MSG I don't know
I was trying to listen to my corner but
I couldn't hear son it was MSG you guys
brought more energy to MSG mixer dude
that [ __ ] was yeah you actually calmed
it down at one point the start of the
second round I was like yeah yeah
they're getting too excited I'm like
chill because you almost finished him at
the end of the first
let me work please let me work I was
trying to work but um yeah when I was
trying to get the hooks in I was looking
for the finish a little bit so I was
trying to find the neck but I didn't
want to rush anything yeah because I
know if I've made that mistake in
training many times when you rush
something and then you end up in a bad
position yeah so I was like a be
systematic be diligent and be smart so
again I just drained his enthusiasm drag
him down whoop him whoop him he tries to
get up drag him down whoop him and I did
that I controlled him for like [ __ ]
almost the whole round whole round
basically yeah okay